when that person said to you about you
know Hollywood only kind of make you
more of what you already are um what did
you think at that moment this was how
long ago 10 years no 18 18 18 19 years
ago Wow
I got a little scared at first because I
didn't know like well what what is he
seen you know in me and I knew that I
had certain you know family issues when
I grew up it's kind of what got me into
art I could say the creative role but I
think also he was genuinely concerned
because he saw a decent person who had
an idealistic view and there's nothing
wrong with that
but at the same time it's I think when
you're younger it's just a position not
of stupidity or foolishness but maybe
just ignorance because you don't have
that experience yet to know when you're
tempted with you know something that you
you if you had your parent there it
certainly wouldn't be happening you know
you wouldn't be contemplating well maybe
I should but in the moment you don't
realize that in when you're open and
you're sensitive some of that can come
from trauma and you don't realize that
your reality as you see it in front of
you is actually a reflection of that so
every choice that you make seems
reasonable but it may be coming from a
place of fear it may be coming from a
place of reaction where you had to do
something I mean I this is some of the
stuff I've learned but where people who
are criminals I'm just taking this as an
extreme we see high speed car chases all
the time right we all know how that ends
every time for the last 20 years we've
been seeing how the car chase ends when
the cops are following you you don't get
away but yet time and time again people
continue to do that reason being and
what I've learned in my research in my
own discovery not that I'm
criminal but but that a lot of what we
do that is that is irrational to the
outside is in fact rational to us
because it's a it's a positive behavior
that warded off something else earlier
in life and it's been imprinted in us
that this is what gives us a positive
outcome totally unconscious of it
totally about a set of certain you know
like choices you wake up every morning
you have certain choices and this person
over here has a different set of choices
given their environment their background
the way they think about things so when
he said that to me I I didn't understand
the depth of it but coming full circle
now I would give that same advice to any
young person who's coming out to LA not
as a caution about them but to be
mindful of yourself and watch how you
respond how you think how you act
according to what is presented in front
of you and that takes unfortunately
sometimes it takes experience of some
very difficult decisions that you make
at the time that seemed right or maybe
you know not not so bad but then as it
played out you realized wow I I really
did screw up there or I made a bad
choice and I went against my gut
instinct I think that's the best I will
say this anybody who's listening that
this your gut instinct is probably your
best choice the first thing that you
think about in in reaction without
knowing any information is probably the
most honest of anything as opposed to
trying to logically talk your way
through it you know I've had situations
where I wanted certain people to be a
part of our projects and didn't realize
that they didn't want to be a part of
our project they needed a paycheck fine
you know that's their right but because
I felt that I needed them I limited my
choices to that
individual and attached myself to the
idea that I had to make that work as
opposed to opening up and looking at all
the other possibilities that are out
there now that sounds very rational and
logical but at the time it was personal
it was emotional that I was attached to
having needing to have that person in
order to validate what I was doing and
when to get it that's my own personal
issue but if I'm not exploring that and
looking at the consequences of that
thinking and that behavior and the
outcomes that it gives me then I only
have one of two choices I'm gonna be
completely stubborn and I'm gonna be I'm
gonna force it or all of that time
energy and effort that I'm using I can
use to look open and outward and look at
other people who may be able to to give
me those things that I want that I truly
want to find and find the best match and
experience has taught me that that's a
very good thing to do so well it's not
just all so - I think falling prey to
temptation I know they say sometimes
like recovery meetings are held in Vegas
to test your song the test your sobriety
and every trigger you have a V Las Vegas
but but flattery and that's something
that as a young person you know you walk
down the street and you get someone
stopping their car and saying you would
be perfect for this and especially - if
you're coming with a set of let's get
really therapist T tools that aren't you
know maybe the best that is gonna be
like you're gonna hear angels mm-hmm and
so if you see that enough then you you
would be prey to other things as well
and so I think flattery and it can
happen later on it can happen and you
don't realize that sometimes you'll
never hear from that person again and
that that is the thing that you kind of
have to guard yourself up yeah that's
that's an experience that I found
like I've had people sit down with me
Full Tilt with meetings having watched
our previous films having read the
script and offering a ton of things and
I like this sounds great and then
nothing and I'm gonna woman introduce
you to this person that person you know
I I don't know what that person's
motivations were or or not but to spend
my time getting upset about it or
obsessing over it or trying to figure
out that person's problem and then look
it you know I guess it only hurts me in
the end but I've I've encountered that
before where you know you can be very
you know early on in my career out here
as an actor in fact it's you know you
know going out on a business meeting and
having things not you know and when
we're talking about an era of me - it
happens to guys - it's never been talked
about but there are you know there are
people in Hollywood - you know they have
a right to do what they want but when
they cross the line of kind of putting
you in a position where you know you're
not you're not able to conduct the you
know yourself as a person and have to
kind of adjust according to them it's
now you're kind of you're selling
yourself into something that is really
not about you anymore it's about what
you do for that person and and it is
easy you you know compliments are very
easy to give but at the same time you
have to have your own Center your own
self-worth so that you know that if
you're if you're dealing in business and
you want you know you are talented and
you believe your talent or you have
something to offer find somebody who's
looking for that in you like you know
the look and everything I mean I I do
cast all of our films and I have seen
random people that I've gone up to and I
say you know you have a really great
presence just just and I said you know
I'd really like to see what you look
like on camera and I mean that in
truthfully because I love discoveries of
talent this is how we've been able to
make all of our movies with these
talented
people who are not Union most of them
are not and and not because I'm against
the Union but it just has to do with
cost and everything else that we're
trying to do and we pay everybody but
but it has more to do with you know like
being authentic and being genuine and
and being professional and I think you
can be all of those things and still get
the desired result that you want without
having to do all this other kind of
stuff which is more of like I'm gonna
make you feel good so I can get
something from you which is all they
have to offer use the truth according to
what I see and that could be totally
wrong and you tell me hey goes you know
it's like you get lost but that's your
right all I'm doing is making it an
attempt to try to say hey I see
something here I think there's something
really good here and I'd like to I'd
like to see if it's gonna work for what
I want to do